We've defined P as a set of languages,
but
ultimately we want to talk
about it as a set of problems.
Unfortunately, this isn't
as easy as it might seem.
The encoding rules we use for turning
an abstract problem into a string
can effect whether or
not the language is in P.
Let's see how this might happen.
>> Consider the question, does a graph,
G, have a Hamiltonian cycle?
That is, a cycle that visits
all the vertices exactly once.
Here's a graph, and
here's it's adjacency matrix.
A natural way to represent
the graph as a string,
is to write out it's adjacency
matrix in scan line order.
First a 0, then a 1, then a 0.
Then a 1, then a 0, then a 1.
Then a 0, then a 1, then a 0.
But this isn't the only
way to encode the graph.
We might do something
rather inefficient.
The scan line encoding for this graph
represents the number 170 in binary.
We could choose to represent
the graph essentially in unary.
We might represent the graph as
342 zeros, followed by 170 ones.
The fact that there are two to
the ninth equals five 12 symbols total
indicates that it's a three
by three adjacency matrix.
And converting the 170 back into
binary gives us the entries of
the adjacency matrix.
This is a very silly encoding, but
there's nothing invalid about it.
This language, it turns out, is in P.
Not because it allows the algorithm
to exploit any extra information, or
anything like that, but
just because the input is so long.
The more sensible, concise encoding,
isn't known to be in P.
And it probably isn't,
by an overwhelming consensus
of complexity theorists.
Thus a change in the encoding,
can affect whether a problem is in P.
Yet it's ultimately problems
that we're interested in,
independent of the particulars
of the encoding.
We deal with this problem
essentially by ignoring
unreasonable representations
like this one.
As long as we consider any reasonable
encoding, think about what XML or
JSON would produce from how you
would store it in computer memory.
Then the particulars won't change
the membership of a language in P, and
hence we can talk, at least informally,
about problems being NP or not.